well I didn't leave the face just when I
left the convent first I left the
convent and that was because I wasn't a
very good nun I could see that I wasn't
going to make it it's very difficult to
be a nun or to live a religious life
it's very difficult to live a life of
total celibacy of a life without any
possessions or material responsibilities
at all or are we towed in total
obedience to somebody else and remain
amateur of whole human being and I knew
that I wasn't going to be one of those
there were some nuns in the convent who
were able to do that and were fulfilled
by it but they there were a lot of
others that weren't and I could see that
I was going to go into that category so
with great sorrow I left it wasn't a
wonderful freeing experience I didn't
leap over the wall as we say in order to
travel and wear beautiful clothes and
make lots of money and fall in love I
knew it was going to be awful and it was
awful I'd been in the convent for seven
years from the ages of 17 years old to
24 that's a very formative period in
anybody's life and I totally missed the
1960s which were a huge change in
Western social mores I entered in 1962
and left in 1969 I had my first Beatles
record in 1970 and I'd never even heard
of Vietnam I came out of my convent I
was already at Oxford at that time at
all my fellow students were protesting
against the Vietnam War and I'd never
heard of it there was one time when we
had been told about the Cuba crisis in
1963 which happened shortly after I left
we're after I entered I should say and
we were told that the end of the world
was nigh and so we were all praying
but then they forgot to tell us that the
crisis was over so for three weeks ice
we SAT we're expecting Armageddon we
were very isolated and that made it very
difficult for me to make a comeback to
the world because I didn't know what had
happened though society was transformed
it was as though I'd been like Rip Van
Winkle who went to sleep for a hundred
years and came out and found a totally
transformed and unrecognizable world so
then I left I there was never any great
moment when i stalked out of the
catholic church ah but it fell away from
me i had tried as i thought as a nun to
open myself to God and God seemed
totally uninterested in me the heavens
remained closed and opaque I now realize
of course that I had a very very
inadequate idea of God I was expecting
clouds departs a little sort of whisper
in my ear and of course that's not what
God is God is not another being that
we're talking about something much more
profound so I I think I just found
increasingly the whole boat weight of
theology and Theological dogma
incredible and God remained distance and
unknowable and I just sort of drifted
away from it